[Música]
bienvenidos a ella soy de france 24 en
2018 el gobierno de australia puso en
marcha un proyecto para educar a la
niñez a la juventud en sexualidad y
también en relaciones interpersonales
pero el resultado dado a conocer este
año ha sido duramente criticado porque
nada tiene que ver con la realidad para
la construcción del portal web de good
society se destinaron casi 4 millones de
dólares el dinero se utilizó para crear
más de 350 contenidos que incluyen
vídeos historias digitales podcasts y
materiales didácticos sin embargo esta
es una campaña de educación sexual que
usa analogías con tacos malteadas con
nadar con tiburones para explicar qué es
el consentimiento sexual los mensajes
son confusos e inexactos y también
parecen provenir de una época en la que
la palabra sexo era tabú
la educación sexual es un concepto
relativamente nuevo que compite con
siglos de cultura machista y con una
sexualidad que castiga constantemente a
la mujer y a la posibilidad del disfrute
y del placer sin embargo sorprenden
casos como el de australia que
retrocedió en el tiempo en lugar de
crear herramientas contra el acoso y
contra el abuso gasto un presupuesto
altísimo para poner ejemplos
conservadores y que no se ajustan a la
realidad
en un momento será la conversación sobre
el tema pero antes vamos a ver el
problema
y la buena sociedad o de gustos jet y
así se encuentra en internet el portal
creado por el gobierno australiano para
reforzar la enseñanza en las escuelas
sobre la importancia del respeto en las
relaciones interpersonales vídeos audios
textos y ejercicios prácticos buscan que
niños y adolescentes entiendan lo que es
el consentimiento y que vivan una
sexualidad libre pero sus ejemplos son
confusos
en este clip una joven invita a su amigo
a probar su malteada y ante su negativa
se la da por la fuerza
la agresora es una mujer pese a que los
datos oficiales muestran que el 97% de
los agresores sexuales registrados por
la policía entre 2018 y 2019 en el país
eran hombres debemos enseñarle a las
niñas ya nuestros adolescentes
estamos en un mundo en el que todos
tenemos acceso a la misma información
tanto hombres como mujeres incluso niños
y niñas entonces hay que partir de eso
si todos tenemos acceso a una misma
información porque no todos la manejamos
de la misma manera es decir siempre se
están montando estos mensajes confusos
de cómo se debe interpretar
no sé la justicia del género por ejemplo
cómo se debe interpretar todo
el comportamiento en la calle el
comportamiento en la escuela
la ong en rey pon campus australia en
español poner fin a las violaciones en
los campus de australia señaló que el
material no cumple con los estándares de
prevención de asaltos sexuales y para
maestros como hips la información es
simplemente incorrecta
creo que la única forma de que la
sociedad las comunidades y el género
masculino van a mejorar es teniendo
material explícito creo que no es bueno
usar guantes de seda en estas
problemáticas que han tenido tanto
impacto en toda la sociedad en este
momento las cifras están aumentando no
disminuyendo hasta que enfrentemos esto
de forma fuerte y explícita a las
comunidades no van a cambiar
desde su perspectiva el dinero no fue
bien invertido
entiendo que la educación es parte de lo
que debemos abordar pero es sólo una
parte pienso que no hay suficientes
recursos en las instituciones de base
que apoyan a las mujeres que han sufrido
y que han sido víctimas de abuso y
violencia doméstica allí debería
destinarse el dinero es más que hora de
actuar de que los hombres se asuman su
responsabilidad y de que nosotros
queremos y que analicemos los recursos
hacia las áreas correctas y las áreas
donde realmente se necesitan el gobierno
australiano afirmó que el programa fue
diseñado con la supervisión de expertos
padres de familia educadores y la
comunidad pero ante el rechazo algunos
estados están revisando su uso
de acuerdo al gobierno australiano
especialmente el gobierno de victoria
que es melbourne y el gobierno en new
son huevos que decidieron
y todo este contenido y ya no se va a
circular más en los currículos de los
colegios es decir ya se están empezando
a tomar acciones en contra de estos
contenidos que no están dando ningún
mensaje directo a los estudiantes por
ese lado digamos que el gobierno ya está
trabajando en el tema después de todas
las críticas después de que se lanzó el
programa australia ha invertido más de 6
millones de dólares en the good society
y es un nuevo problema para el primer
ministro scott morrison un venta costa
al practicante que ya fue fuertemente
criticado por un escándalo en febrero
cuando brittany higgins ex asesora de su
partido liberal denunció que fue violada
en 2019 por un compañero de trabajo en
el parlamento
y precisamente para el análisis de este
tema estuvo con france24 la experta
serna bremner ella es la directora y la
fundadora de ong enterate un campus
australia en español poner fin a las
violaciones en los campus de australia
esta activista por los derechos humanos
nos explicó a través de nuestro
corresponsal de camilo montoya desde
adelaida los fallos de esta campaña del
gobierno australiano primero le
preguntamos porque los recursos de the
good society no son eficientes para
educar en una sexualidad sana y libre
estoy entendiendo que no son coherentes
además con la realidad ni con las
necesidades de la niñez y la
adolescencia en australia y por qué es
importante cambiar esos mensajes
confusos o por conceptos claros de
sexualidad
los recursos lo cumplen con los
estándares nacionales porque en realidad
no se dirigen a los impulsores de la
violencia sexual no hablan en absoluto
de violencia sexual no discuten el hecho
de que la desigualdad de género es lo
que impulsa la violencia de género y sin
hablar realmente de estas cosas no
puedes ni siquiera empezar a tratar de
abordarlas y el hecho de que lo hayan
evitado activamente significa que ni
siquiera están cerca de cumplir con esos
estándares parece que piensan que tal
vez es un tema controversial no quieren
admitir que la desigualdad de género
existe en australia y que por lo tanto
es algo que debemos abordar si queremos
avanzar en la violencia de género
ciertamente no quieren admitir que la
violencia de los hombres contra las
mujeres es el problema por lo tanto
existe una renuncia por parte del
gobierno a mantener estas discusiones
abiertas lo que significa que no vamos a
llegar a ninguna parte en este tema una
cosa es el consentimiento cuando uno
dice sí a compartir una malteada pero
otra muy distinta es cuando el
consentimiento es para una relación
sexual le preguntamos a ser networking
sobre este sitio web y de que sigue al
aire al alcance de quien quiera usar los
contenidos diremos que deben cerrar el
sitio web hasta que expertos en
prevención de la violencia revisen todo
el contenido
sabemos que el material que se
proporcionando tiene en cuenta a las
comunidades multiculturales que existen
en australia no se dirige a los
estudiantes al gpp ciertamente no se
dirige a ningún estudiante con
discapacidad creemos que todas esas
voces son realmente importantes y deben
ser escuchadas por lo tanto el gobierno
debe eliminar este recurso hasta que se
incluyan esas voces
todos somos víctimas de una educación
sexual deficiente pero en el caso de las
mujeres hemos sido históricamente
castigadas nuestro cuerpo sometido a
tabúes y nuestras emociones controladas
por las convenciones sociales en
australia una mujer muere al menos cada
semana por violencia sexual cuál es el
mensaje necesario para acabar con ese
problema
escuchamos creo que tenemos un problema
cultural muy grande en australia
necesitamos llamar el problema por su
nombre necesitamos hablar del hecho de
que la violencia sexual la violación y
el abuso son causados por la desigualdad
de género
necesitamos admitir que esto es un
problema en australia antes de que
intentemos empezar a progresar en este
área lo que sabemos es que una de cada
cinco mujeres en australia sufre
violencia sexual a manos de su pareja o
expareja al menos una vez en la vida en
el caso de los hombres es uno de cada 16
y sabemos que las cifras en personas
tlgb te son mucho más altas al igual que
en mujeres aborígenes o de las islas del
estrecho de torres
australia tiene un problema muy grande
con culturas hiper masculinas y
estereotipos de género que son
increíblemente rígidos y no nos va muy
bien hablando de estas cosas simplemente
las aceptamos como hechos y mientras
tanto el mensaje que sí reciben los
jóvenes de proyectos como the good
society es uno de desconfianza esto fue
lo que nos dijo brebner lo que nos han
dicho las víctimas es que sienten que el
gobierno se está burlando de ellas del
dolor y del daño que han sufrido vídeos
como el de la mayor agarre vehiculiza en
la violencia sexual lo hacen parecer un
chiste y eso es lo que sienten las
víctimas que nosotros apoyamos el
gobierno parece pensar que los jóvenes
son idiotas parece pensar que debe
hablarles como si no entendieran el
gobierno subestima la inteligencia de
los jóvenes al publicar este tipo de
recursos que se supone van dirigidos a
jóvenes de 16 17 y 18 años es posible
que haya al menos una víctima en cada
salón de clases y algunos de sus
contenidos
y culpan a las víctimas hay una alta
posibilidad de que haya revictimización
como resultado de este programa
y ya para el cierre son más de 6
millones de dólares invertidos en este
programa que es llamado respectem
matters y en el que se enmarca el portal
web de good society que además se vale
decirlo ya es un título que califica
moralmente lo bueno y lo malo dando un
tono muy condenatorio a la libertad
sexual de esos 6 millones casi 4 se
utilizaron para los dramatizados y para
las demás herramientas que hoy son tan
criticadas y preguntamos se votó el
presupuesto a la basura 108 millones de
dólares australianos fueron invertidos
para crear estos recursos es demasiado
dinero para un recurso que no
funcionamos en términos de la cantidad
de dinero que necesitamos para abordar
esta problemática es poco pero para este
recurso en particular es una cantidad
fenomenal para muy poco creo que el
gobierno definitivamente no valoro el
dinero en este caso y desperdició los
dólares de los contribuyentes
un agradecimiento especial para armar
bremner la directora y fundadora de la
ong enterate un campus australia por el
panorama del país y que nos sirve de
espejo para ver las realidades de los
derechos de las mujeres en casa también
un agradecimiento especial a nuestro
corresponsal en australia camilo montoya
y así llegamos al final de ellas hoy por
esta semana pero la invitación es a
quedarse con todas las programaciones de
france 24 y de france 24 punto com y nos
vemos próximamente siga con nosotros
[Música]